que jacques benillouche journaliste
indépendant jacques bénigne je conçois
remercie d'être en direct avec nous sur
rt france alors on lisait les israéliens
continuent de manifester contre la
gestion économique et sanitaire de la
pandémie de kobe de 19 par le premier
ministre benyamin netanyahou alors la
notion d'acceptabilité elle est terminée
là bas je pense qu'il faut d'abord bien
distinguer les problèmes qui sont des
problèmes politiques les manifestations
politiques avec les problèmes se
sanitaire la population comprend des
problèmes sanitaires
la seule chose qu'elle demande c'est
qu'il n'y ait pas de discrimination ça
savoir que nous avons d'un côté là
l'impossibilité de d'ouvrir des marchés
de rue dans les rues ou en plein air et
de l'autre côté on autorise l'ouverture
des supermarchés ont interdit
l'ouverture des petits commerces
les petits commerces souffrent il n'y a
plus rien quand vous avez un commerce il
ya deux personnes en tout et pour tout
il n'y a pas de danger pour les
coronavirus et donc la population ne
comprend pas ces mesures qui sont qui
sont contraires à ce que demandent les
spécialistes vous savez qu'il ya un
comité de coronavirus dirigé par un
grand professeur qui est directeur aussi
de d'un grand hôpital israélien lui
demande à ce qu'on libère un petit peu
la la la la chape de plomb sur la le je
dirais la population de la même façon le
président de la banque d'israël ce n'est
pas n'importe qui et bien c'est lui
aussi a dit il faut il faut que nous à
es12 ayons un peu plus d'air pour que la
population vivent et enfin il n'y a pas
plus tard qu'hier le ministre quelqu'un
qui est un ministre je dirais très
fidèle du likoud commence à dire il faut
que nous ayons quelques mesures c'est
pour ça donc il faut comprendre que la
population est lassé de cette fermeture
de ces fermetures généraliser les
commerces ferment et les gens ne sont
pas aidés comment pourrait on croire
comme en france il y à des endroits où
le
les magasins ont totalement mis la clé
sous la porte et ça c'est une chose qui
est dû aux coronavirus la population
veut bien accepter les mesures mais
quand elle voit que d'un autre côté les
écoles les écoles maternelles sont
fermées ce qui interdit alors aux
parents au maire d'aller travailler etc
alors alors que les écoles talmudiques
de gens âgés par rapport aux veaux par
rapport aux petits gamins de l'école et
bien fonctionne
et lorsque vous expliquer justement ces
mesures de gouvernement comment vous
expliquez que ce gouvernement a du mal à
trouver un juste équilibre d'après ce
que vous nous racontez
et bien tout simplement parce que les
les chefs des chefs religieux sont au
gouvernement
il constitue la coalition et ils sont
sans arrêt en train de faire des menaces
si vous nous interdisent et d'ouvrir mes
écoles talmudiques
si vous nous interdisait de manifester
éventuellement dans certains cas et bien
auront la coalition et on quitte le
gouvernement et benyamin nétanyahou
tombe donc là c'est un collègue un
chantage de la part des des dirigeants
religieux au gouvernement et c'est pour
ça donc les gens disent par exemple la
semaine dernière mariage d'autres qui
est une ville du sud d'israël
il ya eu un un rabbin qui est mort du
coran la virus il y avait 3000 jeunes
3000 personnes qui ont assisté aux
halles à l'enterrement les uns coller
aux autres et une grande partie d'entre
eux refusé de mettre le mas donc c'est
ce que dit la population
d'un côté on a des gens qui font ce
qu'ils veulent qu'il faut qu'ils
survivent dans une zone de non droit
vous savez en israël on a détecté les
endroits où il ya des problèmes ce sont
des villes la plupart du temps et le
ministère va dit aujourd'hui il ya à peu
près des quais des quartiers entiers de
deux religieux qui refusent les
décisions salutaires et honteux on peut
donc imaginer que s'il y avait un
gouvernement qui voulait faire quelque
chose eh bien ils apporteraient des
décider des mesures sanitaires pour
isoler ces clusters
de deux corps d'un virus et ça c'est une
chose maintenant le gouvernement a
profité du corps d'un virus pour
interdire les manifestations vous savez
en israël nous sommes un pays en guerre
et la population n'a pas l'habitude de
manifester
de mémoire de journaliste il y a eu une
main des manifestations en 1971 contre
le lait par les marocains qui se
plaignait d'une discrimination en 2011
on a eu une manifestation la malle ce
qu'on a appelé la révolution des tentes
parce que les gens se plaignaient du
coût de la vie et du coût de
l'immobilier et là nous avons cette
manifestation où les gens se plaignent
de la situation économique de la
mauvaise gestion du coran des virus et
bien sûr il se plaît aussi de la façon
dont le donc on gère le la question
politique à savoir 1 un premier ministre
qui est inculpé et qui continue à vis à
à diriger le pays et donc ces deux
choses alors ces manifestants qu'est ce
qu'ils risquent en quelques mots il y à
des arrestations
iris à cenon une certains ont été
arrêtés dont un général qui est ce qui a
fait vraiment désordre parce que on dit
que ces manifestants ces manifestants
sont des anarchistes n'est pas vrai il y
avait ou de baraki et l ancien premier
ministre il y a déjà des idées des
généraux il y à un ancien chef de la
direction de la police intérieure dont
ce ne sont pas avec ce sont pas des
mauvais esprits et y travailler il n'y a
pas de casque contrairement à ce qu'on
peut voir dans certains pays dans le
monde et bien donc là le problème c'est
que ces gens-là manifeste et le
gouvernement a interdit ces
manifestations si vous manifestez au
boufbowl une amende de 500 shekels à peu
près 125 euros
parce que vous êtes plus de à plus de 1
km de chez vous mais là le gouvernement
a eu tout faux
parce que il a au contraire posé des
prix là au contraire étendu ces
manifestants les manifestants ont dit
très bien puisqu'on peut parler un jour
vous allez manifester
on va le faire chez nous et moi dans mon
petit coin dans une petit quartier de
chez moi de tel-aviv
et bien maintenant il ya presque tous
les jours des manifestants des gens qui
ne sont pas encartés
c'est des parents avec des enfants qui
viennent manifester et ça se répand dans
tout le pays donc on a voulu faire le
limiter là je dirais la manifestation
l'a étendu et on a poussé des gens qui
n'étaient pas au quartier qui ne
manifestait jamais à venir et à
manifester
effectivement on entend bien ce soir là
la colère donc d'une grande partie de la
population d'israël comme vous ne venez
de nous le dire merci à vous jacques
benillouche je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste indépendante